so a few weeks ago I went grocery
shopping and when I walked back to my
car there was a woman and a security
guard there waiting for me hi is this
your car yes someone hid it and then
parked over there what the Fox you know
she told me that he was just like some
really old man and pointed out his car
so I went to go wait there to get his
insurance information and when he came
out of wholefoods he saw me standing
there and sort of like waddled around a
bit like you didn't want to come over
because he knew that I knew that he had
hit me I had to approach me in the
parking lot and say that you hit my car
where my car it's right over there
where did I hit it there's a scrape on
the side sir what part of my car hit it
I don't know I wasn't here you were here
why don't you tell me
I swear god this is like word-for-word
our conversation and to make it worse
when I asked for his insurance
information he said no okay well then
I'm gonna have to call the police okay
okay well then let me just get secure
data from over here so we can make sure
you stay here to the police come fine
my information book I mean I don't know
if it's just cuz I live in Los Angeles
the land of self-entitlement
or this old guy was just being an
asshole or what but Jesus man and to top
it off when I called my insurance he
said he had no knowledge of the accident
whatsoever this whole situation kind of
made me think of like ethics and
morality and how we act when we think no
one's watching I mean have you ever hit
a parked car and taken off or did you
leave a note and I don't know I'm just
the lack of responsibility for one's
actions just really pisses me off
because if you do something wrong own up
to it take some responsibility have
integrity and I get that that's easier
said than done
did you with the bed what no it was the
cat but we all know when it's the right
thing to do shopes Congress I show you
what the bed
okay what do I know
I mean maybe everything would have been
resolved if I handled the situation like
this I have to warn you sir I've been
reading a lot of Game of Thrones lately
and the correlation between how much
violence I read and then how much
violence is in my videos very very I if
you do not give me your trust respect
and cooperation and I'm afraid this
entire experience will be documented
analyze morale aside
I'll see you next Monday
stay awesome Gotham where hate hi the
fuckin butterfly knife at stuff feed
directly foreign so I demand your utmost
respect box for relates very directly
this book fucking a fucking bitch and
the amount and the correlation internet
this is a bit thick right compared to my
videos documented and now Jesus